they're 6 13 here it's a Monday morning
and this morning there's remarkable news
in Alzheimer's research a breakthrough
medication that could help slow the
onset of memory loss and other dementia
symptoms just got Fast Track approval by
the FDA but the drug called lacanumab
still has to prove that it's safe and
effective for patients so doctors feel
confident prescribing it now that
important work is happening right here
in Las Vegas and you may be able to help
I would forget like a first name or I
would forget like
uh I had a number of them you know I was
using you know just 20 minutes ago and I
couldn't remember it and then oh it
would pop up back in order with a family
history of dementia 68 year old Bob
Lathrop is worried he might be on the
same path so he signed up to participate
in the clinical trials of a promising
new drug called lacanumab one of the
benefits of the volunteer situation I
get really really tested Bob passed one
of the most important tests for the
study his brain Imaging like this shows
a buildup of amyloid protein abnormal
cells doctors say can eventually trigger
Alzheimer's dementia lecanumab has
proven to remove accumulating amyloid so
the thought is by removing the amyloid
protein we can actually delay the
progression of the disease neurologist
Dr Charles bernick leads the ahead study
at the Cleveland Clinic here in Las
Vegas testing patients over a lengthy
treatment of locantimab or band 2401 its
clinical name and then we followed them
over time over the five years with
periodic scans of their brain tests of
their memory so we can really detect if
anything's changing the hope is that
after the five years that we would have
the answer of whether treating an
individual early before they have
symptoms can can prevent Alzheimer's
disease dementia preventing the
crippling brain disease would be a
miraculous breakthrough considering
there hasn't been a new medication to
help with cognitive decline in more than
20 years one of the misconceptions is
that it takes such a long time for drugs
to get on the market because the FDA is
so slow when in fact the real reason
that drugs take a long time to get onto
the market is getting enough people to
participate in these studies to see if
the drug really works I don't feel
anything and I still don't know whether
I'm getting it or not but whether I am
or not I'm helping
he sure is and Dr barnick says he's
grateful for volunteers like Bob who
give their time that will benefit all of
us but they need more participants
if you'd like to get involved in the
ahead study trials at the Cleveland
Clinic you must be a healthy adult
between the age of 55 and 80 and a
non-smoker and very important
participants cannot have been diagnosed
with Alzheimer's disease or other
dementia if you're interested you can
visit this website
healthybrains.org forward slash ahead or
call
702-701-7944 we'll also have that
information on 8newsnow.com
so Dr bernick says the idea of this drug
like and there are several others like
it that are also being tested is to get
ahead of the disease before it
progresses and if lecanumab can actually
remove amyloid as it's been proven to do
then it will slow down the disease and
prevention could be the key to treating
the disease Alzheimer's dementia for the
entire future because right now there's
no cure for it and once you've got it
you're just living out there it's such a
horrible horrible disease but to get
ahead of it would be a big step and I
think it's uh I appreciated the
information there about how the FDA may
not be the slow part of this situation
that they're doing what they can but
they need participants in these studies
right right and these studies are very
important because you want to make sure
that this the drug is safe for everyone
to take so really important thank you
for Bob and for Dr bernick to do that
story so